bonjour à tous je suis ravie de vous
retrouver sur Public Sénat interdire le
voile à l'université la question a été
soulevée la semaine dernière par Manuel
Vals immédiatement recadrée par François
Hollande la place de l'islam dans
l'espace public et sa pratique une
question récurrente dans le débat
politique c'est aussi l'objet de cette
mission d'information au Sénat créée à
la demande du groupe centriste sur la
place le financement de l'islam en
France je vous propose ce matin de
revoir cette table ronde avec les
représentants de culte des principales
confessions en France tout de suite
direction votre table
ronde bonjour à tous et à toutes et
merci de de votre présence à chacun et
chacune je voudrais vous rappeler que le
bureau de notre mission d'information
avait jugé tout à fait intéressant
d'organiser une table ronde entre les
représentants des principaux des
principaux cultes pratiqués dans notre
pays pour mieux connaître comment il
s'organise et dialogue ainsi avec les
pouvoirs publics ça n'est pas une séance
de dialogue interconfessionnel mais ce
travail s'inscrit dans notre réflexion
d'ensemble de notre mission sur la place
l'organisation et le financement du
culte musulman en
France plusieurs de ces questions ne
sont pas propre à l'islam d'où la
nécessité d'examiner les problématiques
communes ou à l'inverse les spécificités
de chaque de chaque culte dans cette
perspective donc nous avons le plaisir
d'accueillir parmi nous aujourd'hui des
représentants des des six religions avec
lesquelles le ministère de l'Intérieur
en charge des cultes entretient un
dialogue institutionnel régulier à
savoir les bouddhistes les catholiques
les Israélites les orthodoxes et les
protestants je les ai cité par ordre
alphabétique parce qu'il faut bien un
ordre qui soit le très objectif et sans
aucune aucun autre je dirais critère
bien sûr bien entendu le Conseil
français du culte musulman a lui aussi
été convié à cette table ronde même si
dans le cadre de nos auditions engagées
depuis maintenant plusieurs semaines
nous avions eu l'occasion d'entendre son
président euh le président du Conseil
français du culte musulman n'était pas
disponible cet après-midi pour autant
euh il fait le maximum pour que l'un des
représentants puisse nous rejoindre euh
au plus vite mais pour le moment je je
n'avais pas d'autres d'autres précisions
à à vous
apporter plusieurs sujets donc
retiennent notre attention la formation
des ministres du culte le financement
des lieux de culte ou des actions
cultuelles y compris euh sur des fonds
venants de l'étranger les relations avec
les pouvoirs publics et le choix des des
interlocuteurs en charge de ce dialogue
institutionnel de manière plus
spécifique nous nous intéressons
également à la prise en compte de
certaines prescription religieuse comme
particulièrement ou précisément euh
l'abattage rituel pour la bonne
organisation de notre débat je veux
d'abord donner la parole à chacun euh et
chacune d'entre vous pour 10 minutes à
peu près chacun euh puis euh euh nous
pourrons euh laisser je dirais la parole
à ce qui me concerne à notre
corapporteur madame madame Goulet euh
bien évidemment à chacun de de mes
collègues sénateurs et sénatrices et
puis nous pourrons échanger ainsi
pendant un peu plus d'une heure enfin le
temps est limité comme toujours mais il
n'est absolument pas euh euh comment
figer et nous prendrons le temps qu'il
le faut pour maintenir et entretenir
donc nos
échang vous
comprendrez si je peux me permettre
d'insister un tout petit peu car chacun
d'entre nous devra fa devra faire un
effort de de concision pour nous
permettre de tenir nos délais même si je
je vous le disais nous ne sommes pas
figés et la lumière ne va pas s'éteindre
à une minute précise mais je pense que
pour l'intérêt de de nos échanges il est
préférable que l'on essaie les uns et
les autres je sais que c'est difficile
par expérience d'être le plus concis
enfin je vous rappelle que cette
audition fait l'objet d'une captation
vidéo qui est diffusée en direct sur le
site du
Sénat alors peut-être pouvons-nous voilà
l'organisation je l'ai je vous ai cité
par ordre alphabétique tout à l'heure et
vous êtes placé ainsi peut-être
pourrais-je donner le micro tout d'abord
au président de l'Union bouddhiste de
France Monsieur Oliv révérent pardon
Olivier Rean Wang Jen euh et puis euh je
vous suggérerai ensuite chacun et
chacune dans cette d'ordre de de prendre
la parole pour vous exprimer sur nos
sujets je voulais encore une fois vous
remercier très sincèrement de votre
disponibilité de votre présence cet
après-midi ces échanges sont importants
pour nous pour enrichir notre réflexion
dans le cadre de la mission
d'information qui donc a été je dirais
installée depuis quelques semaines
maintenant merci
monsieur
sur la touche rouge voilà bonjour voilà
donc je voudrais dresser un très
rapide historique de façon à situer
mieux situé disons le la présence du
bouddhisme en
France qui remonte à la fin des années
60 1960
où de très grands maîtres de différentes
traditions sont venus s'installer
quasiment sans concertation hein mais
quasiment ensemble sur le territoire
français notamment des maîtres des
traditions zen bouddhisme zen et
bouddhisme tibétain
euh très rapidement courant des années
70 suite aux grandes vagues
d'immigration notamment du Vietnam du
Laos du Cambodge de de tous les pays du
Sud-Est asiatique touché par les les
événements dramatiques qui se
déroulaient dans cette région à ce
moment-là de très nombreuses communautés
sont arrivées en France et bien
évidemment ont amené avec ell leur
traditions leur culte et leur lieu de
culte alors je crois que c'est important
de de distinguer euh ces deux façons
différentes dont le bouddhisme s'est
implanté sur le sol français les grands
maîtres qui sont arrivés en France dans
les années 60 ont été suivis pour la
plupart par des
Français présents sur on va dire de
souches même si cette expression est
malheureuse mais voilà de de de
tradition et donc les lieux de culte qui
ont vu le jour très
rapidement ont
été mis en place disons de façon
extrêmement pragmatique
euh ce sont des appartements ce sont des
locaux commerciaux ce sont des locaux
industriels euh qui ont été mis euh qui
ont été installés euh comme des lieux de
culte euh très rapidement euh quelques
années après euh on a commencé à
assister à la construction de de de lieu
de culte notamment de temple tibétain
dans la fin des années 70 début des
années 80 euh qui ont été construits non
non pas sur Paris mais sur des régions
comme le Massif central ou le sud
sud-ouest notamment qui ont été
construits comme de des temples
tibétains euh comme on peut en trouver
au Tibet quasiment hein donc ça fait
dans le paysage ça ça peut être un petit
peu surprenant parfois euh on se
croirait dans dans ttintin au Tibet
presque dans certaines régions et euh là
ça a été des vraies répliques de de
lieux de culte des pays d'origine euh
mais les la plupart des communautés
françaises donc
euh ont acheté des des locaux des hôtels
restaurants des colonies de vacances
pour y installer des lieux de retraite
et bien sûr les les les adaptés disons
euh le le plus
possible mais en sans toucher
l'architecture global
euh ce qu'il faut signaler c'est que les
financements de tous ces constructions
qu'elles
soit des lieux de culte se rapprochant
des lieux originels ou des lieux adaptés
disons euh ont été financés par les
membres des différentes communautés euh
par des pratiquants donc et euh ou des
sympathisants et des donateurs qui ont
fait des des dons sous forme souvent
important euh dans tous les cas ce qui
paraît très important pour les
bouddhistes c'est d'avoir des lieux de
culte dignes euh puisque en Asie
notamment le lieu de culte la pagode est
souvent
euh comment dire euh extrêmement
décoré et on en fait un lieu
de un vrai lieu de spécial hein il est
pas rare de voir des gens en Asie qui
préfèrent plutôt que d'acheter du riz
pour leur famille acheter des feuilles
de d'or pour dorer le le le Boudha de la
pagode donc ce sont vraiment des lieux
importants pour les les bouddhistes
euh à titre d'anecdote je voudrais citer
le fait que le principal lieu de culte
pour l'Union bouddhiste de France c'est
la grande pagode du bois de
Vincenne qui
est donc la propriété de la Ville de
Paris et avec laquelle l'Union
bouddhiste de France a une convention
euh donc occupe les lieux depuis
maintenant une dizaine d'années euh
puisqu'il y a ce grand Boudha doré à
l'intérieur
euh nous avons fait pendant plusieurs
années des demande extrêmement
insistante auprès de la mairie de Paris
pour que un budget soit alloué pour la
rénovation de ce lieu car ça c'est un
une construction que vous connaissez
peut-être qui remonte aux années 30 lors
de la l'Exposition coloniale et qui
tombait vraiment en en état de
délabrement assez avancé et donc il
n'était vraiment plus un lieu digne pour
le pour le bouddhisme en France donc la
mairie de Paris a fait des travaux
importants qui se sont terminés l'an
passé enfin fin 2000
euh milieu 2015 et maintenant c'est un
lieu qui qui qui a une une bonne une
bonne présentation voilà alors je
voudrais juste terminer pour en ce qui
me concerne sur la formation des
ministres du culte euh les ministres du
culte dans nos traditions sont formés à
l'intérieur de chacune des traditions
euh et sont pris en charge donc par
chaque tradition bouddhiste les
Tibétains le bouddhisme tibétain forme
les les ministres du culte tibétains les
et cetera dans pour les autres
traditions voilà et je vais passer
maintenant la la parole à Madame minine
triveau qui est de d'origine
vietnamienne et qui pourra mieux parler
que moi des pagodes et des lieux de
culte Vietnamiens qui sont important sur
la région parisienne
notamment
bonjour je suis très heureuse d'être
parmi vous aujourd'hui alors comme dit
notre
président donc
l'implantation de la communauté
euh
asiatique d'origine vietnamienne
laosienne
cambodgienne remonte dans les années
70 et
donc donc nous arrivons vraiment en
vague et euh un petit mot pour remercier
pour plein de gratitude pour la France
qui nous a vraiment très très bien reçu
et qui a permis depuis 70 jusqu'
maintenant une période de calme où les
blessures de guerre ont été
transformé
apaisé alors pour
euh entrer dans le vif du sujet alors
comme dit euh Olivier vangeng la
formation de nos ministres des cultes et
ben en venant nous emmenons avec nous
nos moines euh ils sont des moine
traditionnel démonial aussi traditionnel
formé souvent des l'âge de 10 15 ans
dans les pagodes et la particularité du
bouddhisme c'est
l'expérimentation donc il y a des études
de Sutra mais c'est surtout euh une un
apprentissage les moines et les moianes
doivent apprendre à pouvoir expérimenter
ce qu'ils apprennent pour toucher la
réalité et de ce fait là pour pouvoir
nous euh disons que aider guider les
pratiquants donc durant ces années ces
moines ont ont vraiment acquis un
travail colossal au point de vue social
pour apaiser ces populations très
meurtrie donc cambodgienne
vietnamienne alors qu'est-ce que je peux
ajouter donc voilà don formation interne
donc il faut vraiment 10 ans 20 ans de
pratique à
l'intérieur de la donc dans l'enceinte
de la pagode et confronté à la réalité
de la vie au quotidien ce ne sont pas
des des personnes
cloîrées donc ça c'est pour la formation
maintenant pour le comment est-ce que
les petites pagodes ont commencé à
euh
euh apparaître et ben euh ce sont
d'abord des petits appartements
et puis
après vers les années 80 on commençait à
voir des signes extérieurs avec les
tuiles et les les toits courbés euh dans
certaines pagotes et là la enfin les les
pagottes sont confronté euh à la aux
difficultés
avec la commune pour que ce soit accepté
et et dans les années
90 nous commençons à
avoir des pagodes beaucoup plus
colossales alors je peux vous citer la
grande pagote de
éri qui se trouve dans
l'esson et qui couvre 4000 m car et qui
a un Boudha de 4 m de haut et 5 tonnes
de de poids et c'est quelque chose qui
vraiment impressionne mais c'est
vraiment une épreuve pour la
communauté vietnamienne en particulier
parce que cette pagote a commencé en
1995 avec
une disons un plan de l'ordre de 1,5 à 2
million d'euros et puis après 20 combien
95 et nous sommes en 2015 euh donc de
20 20 ans 20 ans après la la pagote
n'est pas encore terminée
et le montant est multiplié par 7 même
par 8 et comme c'est fait par tranche à
chaque fois que on arrive à faire
quelque chose les normes bougeent donc
ce qui veut dire maintenant même la
semaine dernière j'ai été à la pagode
c'est marqué strictement usage
privé parce que la pagode n'est pas
encore au norme et elle
est elle elle est dans un état bon pas
tout à fait bon comme souhaite la
communauté et il y a aussi d'autres
pagodes importantes à Joinville le pont
et à Vitri
ou là aussi
elles ne sont enfin le bâtiment n'est
pas encore au normes alors les autres
petites pagodes euh bon dans la surface
est de 70 100 150 m² alors ça va on mais
là aussi c'est pas quelque chose toutes
les presque toutes les pagodes
asiatiques ne sont pas encore vraiment
au normes pour recevoir le public les
personnes handicapées donc ça c'est pour
parler donc le financement le
financement donc comme a dit Monsieur
Vanin c'est surtout dû à la générosité
et à la solidarité et il est important
de dire que dans les préceptes
bouddhistes il y a un précepte qui euh
demande enfin qui essaie
d'arroser chez les pratiquants les
graines de
générosité donc ce ce qui explique que
des fois peut-être par un peu plus
d'adoration les gens préfèrent manger
moins pour
donner des offrandes au moine ou pour
les feuilles d'or mais les feuilles d'or
je crois pas que ça existe en France
dans la communauté asiatique donc par
contre on peut dire que la communauté
asiatique accentue beaucoup sur
l'éducation des enfants et l'intégration
dans la communauté asiatique se fait
beaucoup à travers l'éducation de la 2e
génération et 3e génération donc
financement qu'est-ce que je peux dire
donc malgré tout on voit des des pagodes
très importantes dans en France de la
communauté asiatique
alors le dialogue
institutionnel on peut dire que donc
j'en ai parlé tout à l'heure de
l'intégration c'est quelque chose qui
est très lent on ne décrète pas
l'intégration je me suis rendu compte
compte que moi après 40 ans c'est
seulement maintenant que je commence à
comprendre comment fonctionne la
société civile française alors n'en
parlons pas de nos moines qui ne parlent
pas la langue
et qui donc ont beaucoup de mal à suivre
les toutes les réglementations et les
lois on est en train de former une Dee
génération de moi
la plupart du temps
euh ce il y a également souvent ce sont
des moines etdémonian
d'origine française euh parce que il y a
un décalage entre cette génération de
moin venu de l'Asie et la société
actuelle
euh est-ce que je je dépasse alors
abattage rituel trois mots nous sommes
végétariens donc il il y a pas de
souci
merci bien merci Madame
euh vous propose de de de poursuivre et
puis ensuite nous aurons les uns et les
autres les unes et les autres de
questions qui vous permettront de
développer sur votre présentation donc
je vous propose de de poursuivre en
donnant le micro à Madame Anne violen
ardelle et anne-esophie de jontom qui
sont responsables juridiques de la
Conférence des évêques de France
alors bonjour Effectivement pour le
culte catholique nous allons faire une
petite intervention à de voir nous
allons pas revenir sur l'histoire parce
qu'elle est longue voilà donc nous
allons aborder les questions des modes
de financement des lieux de culte he et
de la formation des ministres du culte
et aborder ces questions c'est
nécessairement se reporter à la
structure qui porte ces activités et et
aux ressources y afférentes pour le
culte catholique c'est donc
l'association diocésaine l'association
ition duocn c'est une association qui
fonctionne qui est soumis au régime
juridique des associations cultuelles de
la loi du 9 décembre 1905 sur la
séparation des Églises et de l'État je
rappelle que un certain nombre de ces
dispositions
renvoi à celle de la loi du 1emer
juillet 1901 sur les
associations ainsi donc toute
modification de la loi du 1er juillet
1901 impacte nécessairement le secteur
cultuel même quand ces mesures ne
concernent pas directement les
associations cultuelles les impacts en
creux alors il y a donc une seule
association diocésaine grosso modo par
département hormis les diocèses
concordataire euh il faut savoir que les
comptes des paroîes sont consolidés au
niveau de chaque diocèse et que
dépassant le seuil de 153000 € de Don
ces associations sont astreintes depuis
2003 à une publication des de leurs
comptes et à la nomination d'un
commissaire au comptes alors si je
reviens aux ressources elles sont
composées essentiellement de dons hein à
hauteur de 80 % sous ce qu'on appelle
enfin sous différentes formes le Denier
de l'Église qui est le plus connu euh
qui représentent 35 % des ressources
dont défiscalisé grâce au rus fiscales
les quêtes et casuelles qui
correspondent à des offrandes faites à
l'occation de fête religieus baptême
mariage et cetera et qui correspondent à
peu près la même montant 32 % des dons
et ce sont ce ne sont pas des dons
défiscalisés et enfin les donations et
Legg euh qui représentent 12 % de des
ressources face à ces ressources il y a
un certain nombre de charges et donc à
titre principal évidemment le traitement
des prêtres qui est versé à NS ministres
du culte en
activité et éalement les salaires des
personnes employés dans nos structures
et qui représent à l'échelle de la
France grosso modo 12000 emplois
euh et enfin le deuxième poste de charg
importante ce sont les dépenses de
fonctionnement et en particulier
l'entretien
courant des églises chauffage des
églises communales he puisque pour le
culte catholique la plupart des églises
sont propriété des communes et donc
l'entretien courant est à la charge des
paroisses chauffage électricité et
cetera mais également les travaux et les
la construction des des édifices
postérieurs à 1905 qui sont propriété
cette fois en propre des associations
diocésaines alors si je reviens un peu
plus sur la construction des lieux de
culte et leur financement je ne peux pas
ne pas citer bien sûr les les chantiers
du cardinal qui finance une partie de
ses constructions dans l'Île-de-France
en 2014 il y a eu grosso modo 13
chantiers ils aident également à
financer la mise au norme pour
l'accessibilité handicapé et vous savez
que c'est un lourd
budget et puis euh voilà c'est parfois
on a parfois aussi des subventions
publiques quand il y a une partie
culturelle qui à ce momentlà portée par
une autre structure que l'association du
cesenes parfois il peut y avoir aussi un
peu de mécénat d'entreprise pour les
ministres du culte alors nos ministres
du culte qu'on appelle séminaristes
quand ils sont en formation sont formés
dans ce qu'on appelle des séminaires
séminaires qui sont à la charge des
associations
diocésain la formation est entiè
financièrement entièrement prise en
charge par ces associations étude
hébergement repas et sachant que le coûp
s'élève par an alors entre 20 et 22000 €
par par séminariste et sachant qu'il y a
6 années d'études voilà donc c'est assez
simple finalement pour le financement
que ce soit pour les lieux de culte ou
enfin les lieux de culte dont nous
sommes propriétaires euh et pour la
formation des ministres et des ministres
en général les ministres du culte ils
sont financés essentiellement et
uniquement par des dons et absolument
par aucune ressource qui viendrait de
l'étranger en particulier euh je
reprécise que l'Église catholique ne
reçoit absolument aucune subvention du
Vatican voilà alors il faut savoir
qu'aujourd'hui on est face à des
tensions au niveau des des budgets des
associations diocésaines euh dont le les
il y a un déficit de fonctionnement
annuel chronique qui pour l'instant est
couvert par des recettes exceptionnelles
essentiellement constitué pour l'instant
par des dons et les mais il faut savoir
que ces tensions sur ces budgets
s'accroit notamment les chares sociale
par exemple je je citerai quand même la
la loi sur la sécurisation de l'emploi
et le la nécessité de favoriser les
temps partiel avec une durée minimum de
24 he ça a impacté assez
considérablement nos structures
puisqu'on a beaucoup de temps partiel à
titre indicatif le passage d'un travail
à mi-temps pour 20 % des d'un travail de
mi-temps à 24 he pour 20 % des salariés
entraîne une augmentation de la masse
salariale de 10
% il est assez intéressant de confronter
ainsi nos modes de financement qui
reposent à 80 % sur des dons
à ce qui figure dans un rapport du hcva
sur le financement privé du secteur
hcva c'est le commissaireat pour la vie
associative au Conseil pardon le Haut
Conseil pour la vie associative euh sur
le financement privé du secteur
associatif du 13 mars 2014 la part des
dons ne représente que 5 % de leurs
ressources au maximum 20 % c'est-à-dire
l'essentiel de leurs ressources est
constitué de subvention publique de la
commande publique ou de recettees tiré
d'activité lucrativ accessoir ainsi
confronté à une diminution des
ressources le hcva a sollicité la
nécessité de redéployer celle-ci pour
consolider leurs fonds propres et donc
différentes modifications législatives
qui ont été proposées et certaines mises
en œuvre à travers différentes lois en
particulier une des pistes proposées par
le hcva était de mieux exploiter ce
qu'on comprend le potentiel dont et M
Séna mais sachange que de notre côté les
dons constituent l'essentiel de nos
ressources euh et cela c'est notamment
concrétisé dans la loi du 31 juillet
2014 sur l'économie sociale et solidaire
qui a ouvert la possibilité aux
associations dont l'ensemble des
activités sont d'intérêt général de
pouvoir recevoir des donations ETL
testamentaires ceci renforce encore plus
donc la nécessité pour nous de trouver
des ressources d'appoint ainsi que des
pour faire face à nos charges qui
augmentent sans cesse avec une
spécificité quandme pour le culte
catholique c'est que les ministres du
culte sont pris en charge financièrement
entre guillemets à vie c'est-à-dire que
ce n'est pas une variable d'ajustement
économique enfin c'est difficile de
l'envisager sous cet angle euh d'où vous
verrez dans nos comptes souvent des
réserves importantes mais qui sont pour
pouvoir honorer euh la prise en charge
des traitements des ministres du culte
dans le temps voilà je passe donc la
parole à Madame de
jotanon il ressort de l'exposé de madame
la Mardel que les associations
diocésaines ont un souci constant de
renforcer leurs fonds propres afin de
préserver un équilibre financier et de
faire face aux charges dont on a vu que
les traitements de nos 20000 prêtres et
les charges salariales des 12000
salariés en constituent la majeure
partie alors une idée pourrait résider
dans le fait d'accorder l'autorisation
aux associations cultuelles de détenir
les immeumbles nécessaires à la
poursuite de leurs activités je
m'explique il est à noter qu'à ce jour
le droit de posséder et d'administrer
des immeubles a été donné à la plupart
des organisme à but non lucratif
association reconnue d'utilité publique
association ayant une activité d'intérêt
général et déclarée depuis 3 ans au
moins association ayant pour but
l'assistance la bienfaisance ou la
recherche scientifique médicale aux
fondations reconnu d'utilité public et
fondation abrité avec dotation et au
fond de dotation en ce qui concerne les
associations reconnues d'utilité
publique et cell ayant une activité
d'intérêt général ce droit de posséder
d'administrer les immeubles euh qui ne
sont pas uniquement nécessaires à la
réalisation de l' social a été accordé
récemment dans la loi du 31 juillet 2014
relative à l'économie sociale et
solidaire j'ai repris les raisons qui
avaient été invoquées pour justifier ce
droit qui figure dans les débats
parlementaires et qui pourrait tout à
fait être valable pour les associations
cultuelles en effet il est difficile de
justifier que des associations
cultuelles puissent recueillir des dons
et des lèes portant sur des immeubles
mais ne puissent ni les posséder ni les
administrer cela
les oblige à ce jour à les vendre
parfois dans des conditions défavorables
étant préciser que si la vente n'est pas
réalisée dans les mois qui suivent
l'entrée en possession de l'immeuble il
y a souvent taxation pour logement
vacant ce qui alourdit nos charges voilà
une autre idée enfin un autre argument
qui avait été donné pour accorder ce
droit de possession euh c'était euh
l'idée suivant laquel euh on voit pas en
quoi donc une association cultuelle
bénéficiaire d'un d'animal par voie de
l'èg serait interdire de le conserver en
vue de se procurer des revenus
d'immeuble considérant par avance dans
ces cas-là que dé placacement financiers
serait préférable à la détention d'un
actif immobilier c'est ainsi que la
possibilité de faire le choix après
discernement sur le plan patrimonial et
économique et aussi pastoral en ce qui
nous concerne de conserver l'immeuble
donc par le conseil d'administration de
l'association diocésaine pour être
source de revenus permettant pour un
diocèse par exemple de pour voir au
traitement des prêtres et au paiement
des charges sociales y
afférentes je vous
remercie bien merci nous poursuivons
donc maintenant
avec Monsieur Alex
buchanger qui est membre du conseil du
Consistoire central et secrétaire
rapporteur secrétaire rapporteur du
Consistoire de Paris de Paris oui tout
fait tout à fait je vous laisse le micro
monsieur je vous merci la présence juive
en France remonte à plus de 1500 ans et
durant de nombreux siècles les les
communautés juives à travers la France
étaient indépendantes les unes des
autres malgré des période de de
persécution les communautés
juifes-fançaises ont été
particulièrement florissante notamment
sur le plan spirituel il y a de grands
maîtres du judaïsme à tro je parlais de
Rachi ses petits fils les tosafotes il y
avait rabiriel de Paris et bien d'autres
la France est véritablement un vivier de
de savoir et de connaissance en matière
thalmudique il y avait des communautés
et des écoles talmudiques dans de
nombreux endroits en Normandie en Alsace
en région parisienne en Provence et dans
bien d'autres
régions c'est précisé ment en
1791 que les Juifs ont véritablement eu
droit de citer en France et peu de temps
après c'est Napoléon 1er qui a promulgué
deux
décrets le prer du 10 décembre 1806 et
le 2 du 17 mars
instaurant le consistoir Central et les
consistoires
régionaux il a donc
tenu à fédérer les communautés juives de
France sous l'égide du Consistoire ça
été une véritable révolution il y a eu
la mise en place du Consistoire
central également appelé union des
communautés juives de France avec à sa
tête un président et une autorité
spirituelle qui est l'autorité
spirituelle du judaïsme français je veux
parler du Grand Ramin de France il y a
eu quelques modifications en 1844 on a
intégré des laïques au sein de ce
Consistoire central il y avait au départ
SEP consistoires régionaux qu'on
appelait les circonscriptions
consistoriales avec
l'avénement de la loi de décembre
1905 sur la séparation des Églises et de
l'État le Consistoire a connu un
véritable
bouleversement et il y a une période
difficile il a fallu restructurer les
communautés et ce n'est que quelques
années plus tard que le cons histoire
tel que nous le connaissons aujourd'hui
a été mis en place donc il y a le cons
histoire centrale union des communautés
juives de France qui lui regroupe
toutes les
communautés dites consistoriales les
associations cultuelles on ne parle plus
comme par le passé de circonscription
consistoriale mais on parle
d'association culturelle
israélite il y a au sein du Consistoire
central désormais 15 consistoires
régionaux ces consissoir régionaux ont à
leur tête des présidents et le
consissoire central a son assemblée
générale qui est constituée d'environ
personnes un certain nombre de rabins
élus par leur père et un certain nombre
de laïques président de conissoir
régionau président d'association
culturelle
israélite c'est cette assemblée générale
qui élit le président du Consistoire
tous les 5 ans et le grand Ramin de
France tous les 7 ans le grandain de
France est donc élu par ce collège
électoral de 300 grands
électeurs cette Assemblée Générale élit
également les
membres du conseil d'administration du
consissoire
central et le consissoire central donc
le conseil d'administration a également
en son sein un bureau composé de son
président de vice-président du
trésorier le même schéma existe pour les
consistoires régionaux alors le plus
important c'est le Consistoire israélite
de Paris qu'on appelle plus communément
laasspe et aujourd'hui je représente son
président le docteur Joël
Mergy le concissoire de Paris laasspe
est la plus grande communauté juive
d'Europe elle groupe 35000 adhérents
mais ces usagers sont au nombre de
150000 alors ce
conistoire de Paris à son équivalent à
Marseille à Lyon à Strasbourg à Nice à
Bordeaux à Toulouse il y a très
exactement 15 conscistoires régionaux
alors quel est quel est le rôle exacte
du
Consistoire le
Consistoire pourvoie aux besoin aux
intérêts du culte donc le Consistoire
central qui regroupe donc les
communautés juives de France et par voix
de conséquence les consistoires de Paris
les consistoires régionaux ont pour
mission de gérer le culte juif en
France ils ont pour autre mission de
veiller au respect des droits des
libertés religieuses de la formation des
rabins les l'école rabinique qu'on
appelait jusqu'à peu le séminaire
rabinique est une émanation du
Consistoire central et c'est au sein de
cette école que sont formés les
rabins le cursus dure au moins 5 ans
parfois plus et les
rabins issus de l'école
rabinique sont nommés à travers la
France Rabin des communautés Rabin de
ces associations
cultuelles il y a dans chaque région un
grand Rabin le grand Rabin est
l'autorité
religieuse de la
région le
financement le
financement bien entendu se fait par les
don les leges et également par la taxe
sur l'abattage rituel en effet le
Consistoire central les consistoires
régionaux ont en leur sein ce qu'on
appelle le bd qui est le tribunal
rabinique ce tribunal rabinique a divers
missions dont notamment tout ce qui
touche à la cacheroute donc à
l'alimentation aux règles religieuses
liées à l'alimentation dont not
notamment l'abattage rituel et donc ce
sont des délégués du tribal rabiniqu qui
ont été formés pour cela qui sont en
charge de l'abattage
rituel ils sont payés par le Consistoire
tout comme les rabins sont payés par le
Consistoire et précisément ces taxe
permet de pourvoir donc au salaire de
ses délégués et euh
permet également au consistoir de
subvenir à ces besoins qui sont
importants il y a les synagogue les
centres
communautaires et
d'autres d'autres immeubles qui
dépendent donc des synagogues pour Paris
les grandes synagogues telles que la
victoire les Tournelles Notre-Dame de
Nazareth et autres sont la propriété de
l'État mais c'est le Consistoire qui est
chargé de l'entretien de ces synagogues
il y a d'autres synagogues plus récentes
dont le Consistoire est propriétaire il
y a eu après 62 la venue en France des
Juifs d'Algérie puis du Maroc de Tunisie
ce qui a donné lieu à l'ouverture de
nombreus synagogue en région parisienne
et à travers la France tous ces
immeubles sont la propriété des
concistoires ce sont les concistoires
qui les entretiennent ce sont les
consistoires qui sont les employeurs
donc du personnel qui est important non
seulement les rabins le personnel
administratif les
enseignants c'est dire que la tâche est
est importante elle est difficile
difficile par les temps qui courent
effectivement la communauté juive de
France connaît un départ
important de ces membres et de ces
membres les plus actifs qui vont
s'installer en Israël
du fait de l'insécurité qu'ils
connaissent dans bon nombre de de
communes je ne m'étendrait pas mais le
le problème est un problème extrêmement
douloureux difficile ce sont des gens
qui sont français avant tout mais qui
pour
préserver l'intégrité physique de leurs
enfants ont estimé dev voir faire le
choix d'immigrer en Israël et c'est vrai
que c'est c'est c'est ces milliers de
personnes je crois savoir que pour
l'année 2015 elles étaient au nombre de
15000 ce sont des places qui se vided au
sein des synagogues ce sont des
adhérents qui ne font plus de don et il
faut essayer de les remplacer par
d'autres membres c'est une tâche
extrêmement
difficile merci et bien je vais donner
le micro maintenant monsieur Caro SAB
qui est responsable de la de la
communication de l'Assemblée des évêques
orthodoxes de France merci madame la
Présidente et merci pour le pour
l'invitation à l'instar de mes collègues
je vais pas m'étendre sur les l'histoire
ni remonter aux racines orthodoxes de la
France au risque de remonter jusqu'à
Saint- Iréné de Lyon un des grands-pères
de l'église qui lui-même était un
immigré alors qu'il était évêque des
Gool c'est il est originaire tout le
monde le sait dans la tradition de la
région d'Antioche c'est-à-dire de la
région du moy Orient entre la Syrie et
la Turquie je vais plutôt me concentrer
pour un rappel historique très bref sur
l'histoire de l'installation je dirais
des églises orthodoxes en France durant
le 20e siècle parce que c'est là à
partir de ce moment-là que on a une
organisation je dirais socioppolitique
si on veut parler d'une émigration qui
est fournie de différentes origines et
d'une organisation qui s'est euh au gré
du 20e siècle organisé je dirais qui
s'est mise en place petit à petit vers
une logique de convergence je dirais et
de travail de coopération entre les
différentes églises orthodoxes qui sont
sur le territoire français euh si je je
je dirais que il y a une dominante qui
est très importante pour comprendre
l'orthodoxie qui par moment en fait elle
est présentée sous un regard quelque
part parfois de de folklore de la
liturgie des des des belles célébrations
et des différentes origine ce qui domine
là c'est il y a un principe dominant
dans l'orthodoxie dans l'Église
orthodoxe dans son vécu c'est le
principe de l'unité dans la diversité
qui a un principe de base un principe
non seulement je dirais eclésiologique
et théologique mais aussi d'organisation
de l'Église orthodoxe non seulement en
France mais au niveau mondial je dirais
dans l'universalité donc à la fois la
l'unité et la la diversité en France
essentiellement l'Église orthodoxe est
le fruit au 20e siècle euh d'une d'une
forte émigration qui est dû
essentiellement au contexte politique
géopolitique parfois très difficile euh
je commencerai par exemple par la
révolution de 1917 euh en union soviti
en Russie qui est devenue par la suite
l'Union soviétique et donc et
l'installation lesmigration d'une grande
communauté je dirais de communautés qui
ont passé tout le toute l'Europe pour
s'installer en au début en Europe
centrale et puis s'installer en France
donc les communautés russes en grande
partie puis par la suite il y a eu les
événements en Asie mineur qui sont très
importants après la fin de la première
guerre mondiale et donc on voit très
bien aussi la remontée euh traversant la
Méditerranée c'est un chemin que qu'on
qu'on qu'on voit de N nouveau en fait au
21e siècle de communautés qui viennent
de de la région d'ASIS mineur
c'est-à-dire de la Turquie
essentiellement après je dirais la fin
de l'Empire ottoman et la fin de la
première guerre mondiale et il y a eu
par la suite des émigrations économiques
pendant la alors il y a une immigration
aussi antiochienne dû à cette
antiochienne quand je dis antiochienne
c'est-à-dire le patriarcat d'Antioche
c'est-à-dire la région qui recouve le
Liban la Syrie l'Irak le golf Arab
Persique donc un peu les communautés
entre guillemets arabophones mais et on
constate que au début du 20e siècle en
1920 il y a une grande forte
installation de Communauté antiochenne
en Marseille avec de de de des nomes
très important puis par la suite à la
deuxème guerre mondiale aussi
l'installation de nouveau de nouvelles
communautés entiochenne et cetera il y a
par la suite en fait les événements du
Liban 1975 en fait la guerre civile la
guerre des autres comme disait sur le
territoire libanais qui a aussi pousser
beaucoup de communautés libanaises en
venir s'installer en France et il y a
une très forte communauté libanaise qui
installé à Paris en fait essentiellement
ce qu'on appelle un peu les Antiochiens
euh il y a une émigration roumaine donc
par la suite aussi qui est importante il
y a au début c'était des émigrations
soit politiques soit économiques en en
fonction de situation et on voit que
même jusqu'à aujourd'hui il y a une de
de nouveau avec les les frontières qui
s'ouvrent au niveau européen une
émigration aussi interne à l'Union
européenne par exemple des beaucoup de
communautés roumaines qui sont installé
le diocèse roumain d'Europe occidentale
est un des des diocèses les plus
fournies en nombre parce qu'on voit très
bien l'installation de communautés
rouaines en masse donc ce paysage pour
dire que euh c'est essentiellement le
foyer du souvenir au début c'est une
émigration d'une certaine manière
sociop-politique ou économique qui a
poussé des fortes de fortes communautés
Serbes geéorgienne grec arabe russes et
d'autres à s'installer sur ce territoire
à partir de 1967 il y a un un événement
et toutes ces communautés se sont
installées ont épousé je dirais d'une
certaine manière le paysage socio
politique c'est-à-dire la loi 1905 en
grande partie à travers la Constitution
d'association cultuelle euh à partir de
1967 il y a c'est une date clé un début
d'organisation de l'Église orthodoxe en
France à travers la constitution de ce
qu'on appelle le comité interépiscopal
orthodoxe c'est-à-dire tout c'est un
comité informel qui n'était pas
juridique euh qui n'avait pas la
personnalité morale qui s'est constitué
pour que tous les évêques orthodoxes qui
existent en France les Grecs les
Roumains les les Russes et cetera
puissent euh coopérer pardon euh c'est
c'est une autre c'est un autre débat en
fait ils sont ils font pas partie de
l'Assemblée des évêques orthodoxes de
France c'est ce qu'on appelle les les
les noms calcédoniens euh moi je
représente en fait toutes les églises
calcédonienes c'est un débat on va pas
revenir à l'histoire là-dessus euh donc
il y a ce comité interépiscopal
orthodoxe en 1967 qui était un comité
informel jusqu'en
1997 la constitution de l'Assemblée des
évêques orthodoxe de France sur la base
de recommandations je dirais de
l'ensemble de l'orthodoxie euh pour que
il ait des dynamiques de convergence euh
entre les différentes les différentes
diocèses orthodoxes de coopération de
convergence de travail en commun donc
l'Assemblée des évêques orthodoxes de
France est une association de loi 1901
qui a été constituée en 1997 avec une
double perspective à la fois de
continuer tout le travail je dirais de
dialogue écuménique avec nos frères
chrétiens avec les autres religion qui
se faisait de tout au long du 20e siècle
de représentation vis-à-vis les
autorités officielles pour qu'il y ait
un interlocuteur aujourd'hui l'Assemblée
des évêques orthodoxes de France
copréside avec avec les nos frères
catholiques et protestants le Conseil
d'église chrétienne en France le CCF
elle est elle est membre aussi de la
CRCF le Conseil des responsables de
cultte en France donc l'idée c'était à
la fois de représentation de
l'orthodoxie de l'Église orthodoxe
vis-à-vis des autorités de la société
mais aussi de pousser vers un davantage
d'intégration je dirais des différentes
communautés orthodoxes c'est dans ce
contexte par exemple qu'il y a eu
plusieurs commissions qui ont été
organisées à l'intérieur même de
l'assemblée une commission théologique
qui s'occupe de tous les aspects
théologiques une commission liturgique
une commission église et société parce
que c'est très important de suivre un
peu toutes les tendances par exemple les
questions sur le mariage les questions
de l'utanisie les questions bioéthiques
une église pastorale une église média et
information et une église de relation
inter interchrétienne interreligieuse
donc ça c'est l'organisation je dirais
de l'Église orthodoxe aujourd'hui en
France elle est l'Assemblée des évêques
c'est une association de loi 1901 comme
je l'ai dit c'est pas encore au stade
can c'est pas une instance canonique
dans le sens où c'est une église locale
en tant que telle c'est une instance
intermédiaire en attendant
l'organisation de l'ensemble des églises
orthodoxes au niveau international et
d'ailleurs le prochain grand concile
panorthodoxe qui aura lieu en Crète
entre toutes les églises orthodoxes
mondiales va plancher sur cette
question-là mais déjà l'Assemblée des
évêques fait un travail de convergence
et d'intégration alors je je voudrais
euh terminer sur deux aspects j'ai j'ai
cité l'unité dans la diversité à
l'intérieur même de l'Assemblée des
évêques siège tous les évêces qui ont
des des des communautés et des des
associations en fait des des communautés
et des paroisses en France donc tous les
évêques orthodoxes canoniques bien sûr
qui ont des paroisses et des communautés
en France euh l'Assemblée des évêques
n'a pas autorité sur les diocèses en
tant que tel tous les diocèses par
exemple le diocèse serbe le diocèse grec
le diocèse anthurchien ont leur
autonomie en terme de gestion
administrative juridique
institutionnelle et de financement par
contre la dynamique de l'Assemblée des
évêques c'est de pousser vers davantage
de convergence davantage d'intégration
et davantage je dirais d'intégration de
toutes ces communautés euh euh je
terminerai sur deux aspects par exemple
sur les aspects de financement il y a un
principe de base dans l'Église orthodoxe
c'est que c'est le principe de l'église
locale c'est-à-dire que chaque
communauté locale doit elle-même porter
à la fois son pasteur son prêtre sa
famille puisque chez nous les prêtres
sont mariés sa famille ses enfants et et
et la plupart des prêtres en France
d'une certaine manière sont issu de ces
communautés locales donc ils causent
bien le français ils sont formés en
grande partie et je citerai par exemple
le rôle très important de l'Institut de
théologie orthodoxe Saint-Serge à Paris
qui a été fondé en 1925 grâce à la à la
vague desmigration russe de plusieurs
intellectuels et de professeurs russes
donc depuis 1925 la l'Institut d'études
d'institut de théologie orthodoxe
saint-sge forme en grande partie non
seulement je dirais les pasteurs et les
prêtres et les futurs évêques de
l'église en France de l'Église orthodoxe
mais fournit aussi beaucoup je dirais de
pasteurs d'évêques et même parfois de
patriarches il y a deux patriarches de
l'Église orthodoxe qui ont été issu des
bands de l'Institut Saint-Serge donc
elle a un rôle l'Institut a un rôle à la
fois de formation en France mais aussi
de formation pour les autres églises
orthodoxes donc au niveau des
financements comme je l'ai dit il y a
une multitude de situations une grande
variété de situations mais le principe
de base c'est que chaque communauté
elle-même porte je dirais le financement
de son lieu de culte de de de de de son
pasteur et de sa et de sa famille et la
communauté et la la la paroisse elle est
fondée dans le cadre d'un diocèse
certains diocèses la plupart des
communautés orthodoxes en France ont
adopté les les associations cultuelles
de la loi 1905 mais par exemple
dernièrement le le diocèse du Patriarcat
de Moscou a considéré que l'association
diocésaine en fait qui s'appliquait on
pensait que s'appliquait en fait
uniquement aux catholiques en France
mais pas qu'aux catholiques ils ont pris
en fait le le format de l'association
diocésen et ils sont régis sous cette
formelà donc c'est c'est comme ça que
alors les bâtiments sont soit la
propriété de ces églises historiques il
y a par exemple la cathédrale de la rue
d' rue qui a été à l'époque en fait
deszar qui a été construite la
cathédrale de la de de George biset des
Grecs là aussi elle a été construite fin
19e siècle et après il y a une multitude
de lieux de culte qui sont soit en fait
mis à disposition de la part de
catholique ou de protestants ou d'autres
je terminerai sur on n pas d'abattage
culturel sur le le les relations avec
les pouvoirs publics je dirais que un
principe de base pour nous et et ça ça
correspond à au vécu de l'Église
orthodoxe qui croit à la coopération
entre le temporel et le spirituel et ça
remonte à l'empireur Justinien la
théorie de la symphonie à Byzance entre
le pouvoir temporel et spirituel ni le
spirituel doit prendre le dessus sur le
temporel ni le temporel doit prendre le
dessus sur le spirituel donc on est dans
une dans une perspective de synergie et
on dit qu'en France la laïcité positive
la laïcité de bonne intelligence et la
meilleure façon d'incarner cette théorie
de la coopération d'une certaine manière
et donc notre approche ce qu'on cherche
à développer avec les pouvoirs publics
c'est une approche vraiment partenariale
parce que il y a aujourd'hui nous
considérons d'une certaine manière que
la neutralité qui qui est induite
quelque part à travers le principe de
laïcité ne doit pas être une
indifférence ni une distance et je
terminerai sur une opinion personnelle
mais qui correspond par rapport à la
situation actuelle c'est que la laïcité
de bonne intelligence est pour nous
considérée comme une sorte de d'outil
d'intégration c'est une véritable
opportunité pour la France pour
consolider le tissu républicain et le
socle républicain par contre la
communautarisation et ça on le constate
depuis un certain temps qui est une
forme de dérive est une véritable menace
à à la à la à la à la à la à la
République et au socle républicain et
indirectement c'est une menace aussi
interreligieuse intercommunautaire parce
que la communautarisation pousse les
communautés à s'identifier les unes par
rapport aux autres alors que vraiment la
laïcité de bonne intelligence et je je
mets un de de soulignements dessus de
bonne intelligence c'est-à-dire dans une
approche partenari partenarial avec les
pouvoirs publics est une opportunité
pour la France pour encore développer
davantage sa laïcité qui a une véritable
opportunité je vous
remercie merci
beaucoup monsieur jean-diel rooc qui est
le président de la commission droits et
liberté religieus de la Fédération
protestante de France je vous cède le
micro
merci madame la Présidente la Fédération
protestante de France regroupe une
trentaine d'églises nationales c'est un
des reflets la diversité protestante
dans ces 30 églises nationales il a
d'ailleurs puisque ils ont été cité tout
à l'heure une église arménienne puisque
les Arméniens sont aussi orthodox mais
aussi protestants son répartissent entre
ces deux tendances puis il doit y avoir
certainement des catholiques aussi parmi
eux donc il son répartissent entre les
trois une trentaine don d'église
national et une centaine d'associations
et fondations juste pour dire que son
champ d' dépasse le seul domaine cultuel
mais par la suite de mes propos je
m'entiendrai au domaine cultuel en ce
qui concerne donc la formation des
ministres du
culte c'est assez proche de ce qui a été
dit c'estàdire les ministres du cultte
sont formés dans des instituts
protestants de théologie ou des facultés
de théologie de droit privé mais
certains sont aussi formés à Strasbourg
qui est une faculté d'État et la
formation dans les faculté de théologie
privée est entièrement à la charge de
l'église elle dure au minimum 5 ans et
parfois 6 ou 7 ans mais au minimum 5 ans
et elle est suivie ensuite d'une période
qu'on appelle de proposana c'est qui
correspondra à des stages d'application
pratique dans les églises locales à
propos de la formation une question
d'actualité jusqu'à présent l'État
français s'était jamais occupé de la
formation des ministres dans le casre de
la séparation des Églises et de l'État
depuis à peu près un an il semblerait
qu'il s'en occupe et qu'il prépare un
décret sur qui définissant les exigences
à Gard des
homoniers d'une part pour faire
remarquer que la Fédération Protestante
n'a pas été consultée pour la
préparation de ce décret alors qu'elle
est concernée par de nombreuxes honiers
et d'autre part pour attirer l'attention
sur un point important il il est dit
dans ce décret qui ne concerne que les
homonies rémunéré ce qui peut se
comprendre celui qui rémunère a le droit
d'avoir des exigences en matière de
formation mais par contre déjà le
ministère d'affaires sociales a lancé
une enquête pour recenser tous les
homoniers y compris les bénévoles et
donc ça nous a un peu interrogé
que l'on passe d'un décret prévoyant de
rémun d'exiger une formation pour les
rémunérés à tous les personnes qui sont
exercent la fonction d'omonier donc
c'est une question d'actualité puisque
c'est en train c'est en lien avec la
formation des ministres du culte en ce
qui concerne le financement comme ce qui
a déjà été dit le financement provient
essentiellement de des fidèles qui soit
de leur vivant ou de leur décès après
leur mort et je ne peux qu'abander sur
ce qui a été dit sur la disposition de
la loi du 31 juillet 2014 qui exclut les
associations cultuelles des nouvelles
possibilités et qui n'exclut soyons
clair que les associations culturelles
et sans que jamais les auteurs de cette
loi n'est expliqué pourquoi les
associations culturelles sont
exclus
le gouvernement et législateur a le
droit d'exclure une catégorie mais ça
sera intéressant qu'on sache pourquoi
cette catégorie a été exclu et ça nous
ne l'avons jamais su en dépit de nos
questions sur les relationss AC les
pouvoirs public et le choix des
interlocuteurs dans les églises
protestantes les les responsables des
églises sont toujours désignés par
élection pour des mandats d'une durée
déterminée entre 3 et 6 ans selon les
églises et donc les ce sont ces
personnes élues comme responsables qui
dialoguent avec toutes les autorités qui
acceptent de dialoguer avec ell et enfin
sur les prescriptions
religieuses à la fois j'aurais tendance
à dire il n en a pas de particulière
chez protestants et à la fois c'est
l'occasion de signaler une autre
curiosité parmi la nécessité de
fonctionnement des institutions
églésiales il y a l'enseignement
religieux l'enseignement religieux a
toujours existé et tout à fait reconnu
par le 1905 comme une des
caractéristiques des activités
desassociation culturell modèle que nous
avons suivi et pour autant la jourprent
du Conseil d'État considère que
l'enseignement religieux ne fait pas
partie des activités des associations
cultuelles com comprennent qui pourra
juste pour montrer que y compris dans ce
domaine il y a quand même de plusieurs
curiosités dans notre régime actuel je
vous
remercie bien ben écoutez merci merci à
tous et à toutes pour cette première je
dirais étape de présentation donc de de
chacun et
chacune dans dans vos
responsabilités avant de Cé le le micro
à Madame Goulet donc qui est
corapporteur Monsieur richchard
rapporteur et Monsieur richchard co
rapporteur va nous rejoindre mais il é
est en réunion à l'extérieur je voulais
rappeler donc comme je l'ai dit que nous
avions nous avons invité bien évidemment
le représentant du Conseil français du
culte musulman qui n'était pas
disponible mais qui a fait le maximum
pour que l'un des représentants puisse
nous rejoindre donc cela est possible
encore au cours de cette discussion donc
Madame Goulet je vous cède le micro puis
ensuite euh mes collègues s'ils ont des
questions je je prendrai une série de de
questions pour que vous puissiez y
répondre si vous le souhaitez madame Gou
oui merci madame la Présidente merci
mesdames et messieurs Mad la présidente
avec votre autorisation je vais d'abord
laisser peut-être mes mes collègues
poser des questions parce que parfois
après le retourne en séance donc je vais
peut-être leur laisser la la priorité
puisque ce sera peut-être plus facile
pour eux ensuite alors Monsieur Amiel je
crois vous souhaitiz intervenir moi ma
question elle est extrêmement simple bon
tout en regrettant bien évidemment l'ABS
d'un représentant de l'islam puisque
cette commission cette mission que sur
laquelle nous travaillons bien
évidemment était à l'origine consacré à
l'islam qu'en est-il en France je dis
bien en France du dialogue
interreligieux peut-être une réponse
dans l'ordre que vous souhaitez mais
pour chacun chacune d'entre vous alors
le dialogue interreligieux est bien sûr
très important chez nous il est
structuré en principe dans chaque
diocège il ex il existe un une personne
responsable de ce dialogue donc il a
lieu au niveau local mais il a lieu
également au niveau de la Conférence
épiscopale hein puisqu'il y a un service
structuré pour le notamment pour le
dialogue avec les musulmans mais
également avec toutes les autres
religions je c'est c'est c'est quelque
chose de très actif alors moi je suis
pas directement impliqué dans dans ce
dialogue mais j'en entend parler très
fréquemment et c'est quelque chose qui
est entretenu de manière quotidienne et
très active même si on en parle pas
forcément tout le temps voilà et c'est
très important
voilà juste un mot pour dire que je
viens d'Alsace he donc où le rapport le
le le le dialogue inter religieux était
extrêmement pratiqué et notamment
soutenu par la Région Alsace qui depuis
une vingtaine d'années maintenant a mis
en place une vraie structure de dialogue
interreligieux avec un responsable un
pasteur protestant notamment euh qui qui
s'occupe donc qui est responsable de ce
ce groupe et qui est rattaché
directement au président euh Richert euh
donc le c'est un dialogue qui est
présent aussi au niveau de la ville de
Strasbourg mais euh j'ai la chance de
faire partir de ces partie de ces
différentes structure et en plus de de
Carole Sabba évoquéit tout à l'heure le
CRCF donc c'est une structure nationale
qui a été mise en place de façon euh
tout à fait euh informelle on va dire il
y a euh 7 ans mais 6 ans eu et qui
réunit tous les 3 mois les responsables
des cultes français des six cultes
français euh donc au plus haut niveau et
on se voit pendant 3h et on évoque tous
les problèmes d'actualité bien entendu
et euh on fait régulièrement des des
communiqués donc ça va des structures
vraiment à un niveau euh très local euh
voire même paroissial euh jusque
euh au niveau de de des responsables de
cultte en
France Monsieur peut-être l'un d'entre
vous souhaitez intervenir si vous me
permettez merci
euh le le le dialogue interreligieux est
extrêmement fructueux en France il
existe depuis longtemps les amitiés
judéo-chrétiennes les relations entre le
CFCM et le Consistoire sont très
harmonieuses souvent les représentants
au plus haut niveau du CFCM se rendent
au conshistoire et
réciproquement vous avez le Rabin Michel
Sarfati qui a créé les amitiés
judéomusulmanes et qui a sononné la
France pour faire passer un message
d'amitié et de
fraternité vous avez avec la communautés
protestantes des relations qui sont très
anciennes et et et très harmonieuses moi
aussi je suis originaire malheureusement
j'ai quitté ma région natale depuis
longtemps de d'Alsace de Colmar puis de
Strasbourg et du temps de mes études à
Strasbourg bien nous avions des
relations extrêmement soutenues entre le
grand Rabin du Barin
l'évêque les les différents
pasteurs d'autres
interventions moi j'ai eu la chance en
fait de de de participer à la fondation
de la de la CRCF c'est-à-dire la
conférence des responsables de culte
c'était en en novembre 2010 donc comme
l'a dit odivier c'est une structure
informelle mais qui est quand même un
peu la résultante d'une forme
d'évolution je dirais de rapprochement
de plusieurs dialogues bilatéraux ou
multilatéraux qui existaient en France
et comme l' l'a fait remarquer monsieur
le Rabin euh que ce soit au niveau
bilatéral les amiés Judi chrétiennes ou
au niveau multilatéral et donc c'est
c'était une sorte d'aboutissement
naturel la la la CRCF la la conférence
des responsables de culte et l'idée de
base c'était parce que ça représente les
six leaders religieux si on peut appeler
comme ça en fait avec entre guillemets
leaders qui se réunit sur une base
informelle euh pour se connaître et se
faire connaître entre eux pour discuter
sur les sujets d'actualité de mettre en
place des logiques de convergence de
coopération euh et ça a ça a évolué
d'une manière très positive et je pense
jusqu'à aujourd'hui ne serait-ce au
niveau de cette réunion régulière et
fréquente qui a lieu tous les 3 mois et
qui était un peu le sujet de de beaucoup
de de de de papier dans la presse sur
son secret ou sa confidentialité les
journalistes voulaient tout voulaient
toujours savoir où est-ce qu' a lieu la
prochaine réunion et comment elle est
organisé l'idée de base de ces si Liers
religieux était de se retrouver sur une
base informelle non pas dans une logique
de positionnement ou d'un front des
religions vis-à-vis de la société
vis-à-vis des autorités mais tout
simplement de travail de coopération de
de un travail sur le sur la durée et je
pense que déjà ce premier objectif est
largement atteint euh puisque ils se
réunissent tous les 3 mois il y a eu par
exemple un collo qui s'est organisé ici
au Sénat qu'on a organisé au nom de la
CRCF sur la laïcité qui a regroupé plus
qu'une centaine de personnes où les
différents cultes ont pu donner leur
point de vue sur la laïcité son
évolution en France ses ses avantages et
ses inconvénients et comment elle peut
se projeter dans l'avenir euh il y a eu
plusieurs communiqués et tribunes ENIT
qui ont été publié donc il y a une forme
d'externalisation si je peux me
permettre une analyse purement
personnelle le problème c'est pas le
dialogue interreligieux problème à mon
avis c'est le malaise quelque part de
d'une forme de de d'identification de la
religion à un combat qui est un peu plus
socioppolitique et donc donc le dialogue
interreligieux il est profond il existe
et il peut jouer le le facteur comment
dire de de pacification sociale et le la
CRCF l'a joué à plusieurs reprises quand
il y a eu eu des tensions notamment par
rapport à des conflits extérieurs à la
France qui pourrait auraiit pu mettre en
difficulté à la fois les musulmans de
France mais aussi la communauté juive et
donc là là ce facteur d'apaisement de
pacification parce que les leaders se
connaissaient parce que les relais
étaient mis en place donc voilà donc ça
c'est un peu une sorte d'aperçu très
rapide sur sur la CR
CRCF très bien monsieur Racheline vous
avez une question
oui madame la Présidente merci euh vos
exposés étaient très intéressant et je
tiens à vous en remercier aussi une
question que j'aurais souhaité aborder
mais malheureusement le représentant du
du culte musulman n'est pas là et je
crois que c étaé intéressant de
l'entendre sur la problématique du
financement étranger puisque vous avez
tous
aborder la problématique du financement
qui semble être un
problème pour pour vous alors déjà
j'aimerais vous entendre sur cette
problématique en détail sur cette
problématique du financement et pourquoi
pas du financement étranger quand il
existe et malheureusement le le le
représentant du du du culte musulman
n'est pas là mais j'aurais peut-être
l'occasion d' d'en rencontrer d'autres
dans le cadre de cette mission mais
l'entendre sur la problématique du
financement étranger et et parce qu'on
je n'ai pas entendu de de remarques sur
ce sujet et sur l'influence donc parce
qu'on on sait maintenant que pour ce
culte en particulier il est financé
beaucoup par l'étranger particulièrement
la formation des imams et cetera et et
et et j'aurais aimé savoir que pensz de
de l'influence donc de ces fonds
étrangers de ces pays qui donnent
énormément d'argent et et de l'influence
que ça a sur l'islam et et et et sur la
société française donc puisque
évidemment l'un et l'autre sont
désormais
liés bien je je vous rappelle et je
rappelle à Monsieur rachelin que nous
avions auditionn le responsable du CFCM
je ne sais plus si vous étiez là ou pas
mais on avait posé ces questions hein
euh il y a eu un certain nombre de
précisions apporté pour pour cette pour
cette religion je vais laisser vous
laisser la parole mesdames messieurs
oui al pour le le cul protestant un
petit rappel historique puisque j'en ai
pas fait jusqu'à présent en 1685 700
temples ont été rasés donc conclusion
lorsqu'on est revenu à Napoléon le
problème problème s posé c'est sueli la
construction des temples et il est bien
évident que les protestants de France
ont été énormément aidé au 19e siècle
pour le financement des reconstructions
de temples par des églises étrangères je
fait partie des donné de l'histoire de
France donc nous avons été aidés à cette
époque et au 21e siècle après le 20e des
églises étrangère Contin continu à aider
des églises protestantes pour
l'édification leur édifice du culte
c'est une réalité il y a aucune raison
de la cacher mais ce n'est pas parce
qu'ils aident pour l'édification
financière des édifices du culte que
pour autant ils interviennent dans la
conduite des églises locales comme ça a
été dit tout à l'heure chaque église
locale est autonome dans le cadre de
l'organisation de l'Église à laquelle
elle appartient mais il n'y a pas
d'influence étrangère en la matière mais
il y a des financements étrangers qui
ont toujours été minoritaires je il faut
pas non plus les
surestimer merci mesdames messieurs de
de
précisions
JEM
à Madame
Goulet oui merci beaucoup madame la
Présidente merci beaucoup pour pour ces
exposés donc j'ai j'ai beaucoup de
questions
euh la première sera assez simple en ce
qui concerne euh monsieur rock vous
mentionnez des des financements
étrangers est-ce que vous pourriez nous
dire comment il
transit parce que vous savez qu'en ce
qui concerne l'islam on avait cette
fondation pour les œuvres de l'islam de
France avec une hypothétique
euh organisation qui aurait permis la
transparence parce qu'en réalité les
fonds venus de l'étranger ne posent pas
30 de problème un s'ils ne sont pas
corrollés et deux s'ils sont
transparents donc ça fait deux
conditions qui sont cumulatives et non
pas alternatives donc est-ce que vous
pvez me dire comment euh les euh les euh
les financements sont euh transit euh la
2uxe question et est pour Monsieur
Buchinger alors là j'en ai j'en ai
plusieurs euh la première
c'est l'organisation des listes
électorales puisque vous avez parlé à
plusieurs reprises d'élection comment
est-ce que sont composé les listes
électorales pour le Consistoire ou les
consistoires régionaux parce que c'est
relativement important vous avez quelque
part une organisation idéale en ce qui
concerne la représentativité et et
l'élection et et manifestement donc ça
c'est la première chose la deuxième
chose je voudrais avoir une une une idée
si vous l'avez si vous pouvez nous la la
nous l'a donné du montant euh que
représente le département cach-erout et
et et viande cachè parce que ça nous
permettrait d'avoir aussi une une
comparaison comparaison n'est pas raison
mais en même temps en terme d'abattage
il y a quand même des liens extrêmement
fort avec l'abattage rituel musulman euh
avec la certification avec même si c'est
pas exactement identique il y a quand
même là euh beaucoup de points de de
comparaison qui pourrai être euh utille
utile à à à nos travaux euh pour le
reste je n'ai pas beaucoup de questions
sauf à dire qu'à euh auil pentou nous
avons un un temple euh dans l'Orne nous
avons un temple le dail Lama était venu
d'ailleurs le visiter pour le reste j'ai
j'ai j'ai pour l'instant euh pas trop de
de questions à vous poser euh mais euh
mais ces deux ces deux points
m'intéresserait beaucoup en terme de de
comparaison parce que vous vous voyez
bien que euh la difficulté dans le cadre
de de la mission c'est d'essayer de
d'avoir une idée précise de la façon
dont les choses sont organisées parce
qu'à la fois l'État ne peut pas
intervenir dans l'organisation et à la
fois il intervient quand même à un
moment ou à un autre que ce soit
fiscalement ou que ce soit pour des
règles dont vous venez de nous dire à
quel point elle pouvait perturber le
fonctionnement qui serait un
fonctionnement normal parce qu'il est
parfaitement évident que si vous pouvez
recevoir des dons d'élèges et bénéficier
de revenus de l'immobilier ce sera quand
même beaucoup plus simple pour le
financement que si vous ne pouvez pas le
faire donc pour l'instant ce sont mes
deux premières questions merci madame la
Présidente alors peut-être monsieur pour
être dans l'ordre de vos questions puis
monsieur
bchanger alors en ce qui concerne les
les financements de construction desdfic
du cul par des églises étrangères les
églises envoyaient les donents qu'elles
avaient recueilli directement aux
églises de France directement maintenant
il y a une fondation du protestantisme
qui a été créée reconnuet publique en
2001 qui a d'ailleurs un peu été utilisé
comme modèle pour l'autre fondation à
laquelle vous faisz allusion et celle-ci
a reçu ou plutôt va recevoir des dons
venants de fondation américaine pour le
même objet mais c'est un projet récent
c'est Don un développement nouveau en la
matière quand je peux commencer aussi à
répondre à votre deuxième question sur
les listes parce que c'est une question
qui s'est posée pour les protestants dès
1852 puisqueen 1852 il y a eu un décret
qui a créé le suffrage universel
masculin certes mais c'était un début il
est devenu féminin dès 1906 et donc
depuis 1852 puis 1906 il y a dans chaque
association cultuelle une liste de
membres et c'est à partir de cette liste
de membres qu'ont lieu toutes les
élections dont j'ai parlé
également
merci donc en en préambule je je
j'indiquerai que le Consistoire Central
et les différents consistoires régionaux
ne bénéficient d'aucun financement
étranger donc c'est précisant que je
souhaitais apporter en ce qui concerne
les membres des différents consistoires
ce sont des adhérents qui verse une
cotisation cette cotisation est d'un
montant minimal de 60
€ le shabbat lors des offices religieux
des personnes sont appelées à la Torah
et sont amenées à faire des dons ces
dons précisément leur permettent de
devenir adhérent du concessoire de Paris
de Marseille de Lyon de Strasbourg donc
ce sont des adhérents qui sont amenés à
faire des dons dans le casadre des
offices religieux et qui décident de
leur propre initiative en dehors des
offices de devenir membrre en versant
cette cotisation de 60 € c'est ainsi que
pour Paris et la région parisienne qui
regroupe environ 300000 personnes de
confession juive les adhérents sont au
nombre de 35000 c'està-dire grosso modo
10 % des usagers des différents services
du
Consistoire et vous me posiez une autre
question à savoir quelle
était la côte part de la taxe sur
l'abattage
rituel dans le budget du conshistoire
elle est importante elle représente
entre 30 et 35 % des ressources
notamment du Consistoire de Paris
j'avais une petite question également
plus particulièrement à Monsieur
bchanger concernant
donc l'abattage rituel et la taxe est-ce
que vous pourriez nous indiquer comment
les choses s'organisent la taxe est-elle
perçue à la vente de la viande est-ce
qu'elle calculé ou estimé à un autre
moment et également qu'en est-il comment
les choses s'organisent aussi
sur certification l'agrément donné à à
ceux qui peuvent donc procéder à cet
abattage rituel alors la la taxe elle
est calculée au kilo de viande
elle est euh versé par les chevillards
donc les grossistes en viande et les
délégués qui sont chargés donc de
l'abattage rituel sont des personnes qui
bénéficient d'une formation extrêmement
sérieuse longue et ce sont des gens
expérimentés ce ne sont pas des gens qui
vont s'improviser dans l'abattage rituel
ce sont des gens qui avant de pouvoir
procéder à ces abattages ont fait des
études extrêmement longue et minutieuse
tant sur le plan théorique que sur le
plan
pratique je voudrais préciser si vous le
permettez au niveau de de l'abattage
rituel un problème dont on on parle
beaucoup la
Torah comprend 613 commandements et
parmi ces 613 commandements il y en est
un qui est l'interdiction de faire
souffrir l'animal et c'est précisément
la raison pour laquelle cet abattage
rituel a été instauré depuis les
origines dans le but de ne pas faire
souffrir l'animal alors il y a des
débats je les ai suivis j'y ai même
participé avec le grand Ramin fison qui
a l'avantage d'être à la fois grand
Ramin de la Moselle et médecin
vétérinaire
le but de cet avattage rituel ce qu'on
appelle en hbrolasherita est précisément
d'éviter autant que faire ce peu la
souffrance
animale les uns et les autres avaient
indiqué que évidemment la laïcité ne
posait strictement aucune aucune
difficulté est-ce que est-ce que vous
vous
pouvez m'indiquer
si si vous pensez que les choses sont
plus simples sous un régime
concordataire
ou
ou pas parce que certains certains
certain des certains des personnes qu'on
a entendu euh estimit que éventuellement
le régime concordataire semblait
évidemment un système plus performant
plus simple pour régler un certain
nombre de problème et évidemment
certains rattrapages en fonction de de
religion qui serait sur notre territoire
depuis moins longtemps que la religion
catholique ou que la religion juive euh
ou protestante ou orthodoxe enfin pour
avoir un certain rattrapage en fonction
de ce qui s'est passé un peu avant la
loi de 1905 donc quel est quel est votre
sentiment sur sur ce sur ce ce concordat
j'ajoute que le dialogue interreligieux
en
Alsace et ça on l'a vu dans le casre
d'une autre mission avait notamment
permis une appréhension notamment dans
les écoles de la minute de silence après
Charlie qui s'était passé nous attend
dit beaucoup mieux qu'ailleurs et où il
y a pas eu d'incident donc
ce cette ce fait religieux à l'école en
tous les cas dans le dans le cadre
concordataire et celui-là uniquement
semble quand même apporter un certain
nombre de d'apaisement en tous les cas
et et probablement lutter contre
l'ignorance qui est qui est quand même
notre notre en général notre pire et
demi c'est pour ça que que nous sommes
là est-ce que je est-ce que je pourrais
avoir votre votre avis sur le
sujet effectivement je crois que
l'enseignement laïque du fait religieux
est quelque chose de très important et
on ne peut que regretter d'ailleurs les
retards qui ont été constatés pour sa
mise en place dans la France de
l'intérieur pour faire la comparaison
mais
euh le problème de l'Alsace et de la
Moselle et des religions qui ont un
statut parce que le Concordat ne
concerne que l'Église catholique pose le
problème de
l'égalité puisque les religions qui ont
bénéficie en sont très contentes et on
ne peut qu'en prendre acte mais celles
qui n'en bénéficie pas font remarquer
que la situation n'est pas conforme à
principe de la Constitution qui est
l'égalité des citoyens et c'est là la la
difficulté du de la vie qui a été rendue
par le Conseil constitutionnel c'est
qu'il a dit expressément que le régime
actuel ne pouvait pas être étendu ça
veut dire que le régime actuel est un
régime qui est cristallisé et qui ne
saurit être étendu d'après ce qu'a dit
le Conseil constitutionnel à d'autres
religions or ça concerne les musulmans
mais ça concerne aussi les églises
évangéliques qui ne bénéficient pas de
ce régime qui ne concerne que les
luutérux réformés en Alsace donc c'est à
la fois
positif ce qui est gênant c'est qu'il
soit pas possible de l'étendre à
l'ensemble des cultes
concernés si vous le permettez moi qui a
vécu qui a vécu en
Alsace
durant une vingtaine d'années j'ai pu
constater que ce régime concordataire
était un
régime
favorable aux religions alors bien
entendu aux grandes religions la
religion catholique la religion
protestante la religion juive les les
rabins les curés les pasteurs sont des
agents de l'État et cela simplifie
considérablement les choses pour ces
diff différent religion
car leur salaire leur salaire en grande
partie provient de leur statut de de
fonctionnaire maintenant il est vrai
que dans ce qu'on appelle la vieille
France donc en dehors de l'Alsace et la
Moselle ce régime n'existe pas
mais les communautés parviennent
parfaitement à subvenir à leurs besoins
mais c'est vrai que ce régime
concordataire simplifie grandement les
choses pour ces différentes
religions alors pour à la fois avoir des
relations assez suivies avec la mairie
de Strasbourg et la mairie de Paris pour
les raisons que j'évoqué tout à l'heure
notamment la gestion de la Grande
Pagode euh je peux témoigner vraiment
que euh les les les relations entre les
pouvoirs publics
et les les cultes sont vraiment plus
apaisé en Alsace en tout cas
euh cette lecture de la laïcité qui est
peut être à un moment donné quand même
lu disons ou
interprété avec plus ou moins de rigueur
euh prête parfois à des des situations
un peu hubuesques notamment au niveau de
de de de la Mairie de Paris où les
choses peuvent être culturelles à un
moment donné basculer dans le
cultuel sans qu'on comprenne vraiment
pourquoi ou le contraire d'ailleurs et
en fait on joue beaucoup avec cette
ambigué en permanence et ça ça fait des
des des des des choix qui sont parfois
mal mal compris de part et d'autrre
voilà à titre d'exemple pratique
euh il y a une pagode vietnamienne qui
est en cours de construction dans la
dans la banlieue strasbourgeoise à la
vseno enfin la robero plus exactement et
dans ce type de travaux d'un montant de
1500000 ou 1800000 € la mairie de
Strasbourg participe à hauteur de 10 %
en plus d'un bail
amphitthéotique et la région Alsace
participe à hauteur de de 10 % également
ce qui fait que les les les frais
engagés sont bénéficies disons de de de
20 % de
d'argent public mais c'était pour
respecter ce qui avait été fait pour la
grand la construction de la Grande
Mosquée quelques années plus tôt où là
aussi la ville et la région ont
participé à hauteur de de 20
%.
pour ma part pour notre part en tout cas
euh je pense que le Concordat est une
des modalités de la République laïque le
compteorda d'alsas Mosel est une des
modalités de la République laïque qui
s'oppose pas à la laïcité c'est une
autre manière de décliner la laïcité ce
qu'on peut constater dans les faits
c'est qu'effectivement le fait religieux
a été mieux pris en compte et que du
coup il y a eu moins de
d'incompréhension probablement entre les
les d'une part les pouvoirs publics et
les cultes et les entre les cultes mêmes
euh voilà moi ce que je dirais pour la
partie alasmosel
merci moi je voulais faire un
commentaire un peu dans le même sens de
ce que disait Anne violen c'est que le
problème c'est pas le la religion mais
c'est l'intégration de la de la religion
je dirais dans l'espace public d'une
certaine manière et c'est une question
de philosophie et de construction de
rapports qui sont non ambigu entre les
autorités publiques et les religions et
les responsables en fait cultuels et et
et et euh je prends un exemple un peu
d'une certaine manière concordataire par
exemple l'église de Grèce qui souffre
beaucoup aujourd'hui de cette situation
où l'État en fait payent les les les
prêtres les fonctionnaires et donc ça
crée à la longue parfois en fait parfois
des avantages parfois des des des
inconvénients mais le problème c'est pas
le régime concordataire ou une laïcité
un peu à La Jacobine à problème c'est la
manière dont on conçoit les relations
entre les pouvoirs public et les
religions et dont on conçoit le
l'intégration du fait religieux à
l'intérieur même de la société euh et et
soit on cherche à le garder à distance
soit on cherche à le à faire une
intégration qui est plutôt harmonieuse
et de coopération et c'est ça à mon sens
tout l'enjeu je pense que la laïcité en
France a à son avantage une évolution
tout au long du 20e siècle et on a vu
que au niveau du droit positif et au
niveau des arrêts du Conseil d'État et
de il y avait des évolutions qui sont
intéressantes mais à chaque fois on on
sent que il y a parfois des rechutes qui
qui font que tous les acquis et les
évolutions qu'on a euh parfois retombe à
travers cette ambiguïé qui cette dualité
qui continue à exister euh si je donne
une image peut-être un peu de la
situation c'est comme si on a eu une
naissance mais on a oublié de couper le
cordon ombilical et donc quelque part on
est un peu dans cette situation où on
est rattaché et pas rattaché ce qu'a
cité jeandiel tout à l'heure sur
cette disposition qui ne concerne que
les les associations cultuelles jusqu'à
aujourd'hui on comprend pas pourquoi ça
ne concerne que les associations
cultuelles donc il y a toujours des
ambiguïés comme ça qui par moment
reviennent et ça crée beaucoup de
d'incompréhension et de mésintelligence
alors que on peut le constater sur la
durée tout au long du 20e siècle que ce
soit dans le cadre du rapport Machelon
ou dans le cadre par exemple du groupe
juridique interculte on a travaillé en
très bonne intelligence pendant 3 ans
pratiquement dans le cadre du ministère
de l'Intérieur et ça promettait beaucoup
parce que pour nous c'était un forum
dans lequel on était pas dans des
relations bilatérales on était dans des
relations multilatérales mais avec les
autorités pu publque c'est-à-dire le
fait religieux concernait les deux
parties mais non pas perçu d'une manière
jacobine c'est-à-dire de haut en bas
c'est un peu dans ce que je disais tout
à l'heure de l'approche partenariale et
et je pense que ça c'est quelque chose
qui est important de de de voir que il y
a la conception de l'État doit d'une
certaine manière évoluer sur ces
questions-là euh l'approche partenariale
c'est une app approche synergétique
entre des acteurs de la société pour
qu'il y ait davantage de convergence
entre eux on le voit très bien par
exemple développement des des projets
publics privés par exemple ça c'est une
approche partenariale parce que l'État
n'arrive plus aujourd'hui sur un
beaucoup de sujets à être le seul
ordonateur exécuteur et et et donc le
fait religieux en fait partie de ces
questions régaliennes de ces questions
qui sont hyper sensibles hyper
importants pour la société dans lequel
le besoin d'une vraie approche
partenariale est est de plus en plus
important et et Infiné peu importe les
dispositions du Concordat ou d'une
laïcité un peu à la de la intérieur
c'est c'est cette questionlà qui
nécessite d'être tranchée à mon sens
madame Goulet pour de nouvelles
questions oui merci madame la Présidente
je voudrais pas laisser penser que le le
débat qui s'est instauré à propos de
Strasbourg laisse penser à une une
seconde que que nous que nous
envisageons ne serait-ce que d'un yota
de bouger la loi 1905 il est
parfaitement clair que il est totalement
immuable sur le fond la forme et dans
notre esprit dans celle de de cette
commission euh j'ai plusieurs enfin j'ai
j'ai deux questions à
poser
globalement premièrement
l'enseignement l'enseignement privé
qu'il soit catholique ou juif ou s'il y
en a un autre protestant comment est-il
organisé comment est-il
financé et puis la deuxième question
euh le contrôle des
conversions comment ça
fonctionne les gens qui se convertissent
quel est leur quel est leur programme
progamme de conversion quel est le le
suivi quel est le le
parrainage comment comment est-ce que
comment est-ce que ça fonctionne voilà
merci si vous le permettez je vais
répondre à ces deux question concernant
l'enseignement donc les écoles privées
confessionnelles juives il y en a un
certain nombre à travers la
France principalement en région
parisienne et ces écoles sont
généralement sous contrat avec
l'Éducation
nationale on a tous entendu parler de ce
livre qui est paru au début des années
2000 les territoire perdu de la
République il est devenu extrêmement
difficile voire impossible dans
certaines communes dans certaines
banlieu pour des les enfants de
confession juives de pouvoir bénéficier
de l'école publique laïque et
républicaine c'est un véritable drame
pour un grand nombre de familles qui
n'envisageaient pas de mettre leurs
enfants dans les écoles privées qui
eux-mêmes ont toujours bénéficié de
l'enseignement public mais la montée de
ce nouvel antisémitisme a fait que ces
difficultés a amené bon nombre de
familles à diriger leurs enfants vers
les écoles juives privées voire parfois
vers des écoles catholiques privées
parce qu'effectivement pour préserver
leurs enfants
de d'insultte de cou voire pire encore
bah la solution ça a été l'école privée
donc les les écoles juives dans leur
majeure partie sont des écoles sous
contrat avec l'éducation nationale
l'enseignement est l'enseignement
absolument identique à celui qui est
dispensé dans toutes les éces lycé
collège public il y a dans ces écoles
privées des cours de de de de bible des
cours de talmude des cours de pensées
juiv alors en fonction des écoles ça
peut être 2 heur par jour 3 heur par
jour voir peut-être plus mais l'objectif
est toujours de faire en sorte
que le programme de l'éducation
nationale soit scrupuleusement
respecté vous avez évoqué le problème
des conversions alors si vous le
permettez la religion juive a une
spécificité par rapport aux autres
religions c'est qu'elle n'est absolument
pas prosélite
elle ne cherche d'aucune manière à
voulloir convertir qui que ce soit
mais tout en chacun
qui aurait la foi la volonté de se
convertir au
judaïsme peut le faire et la suite de
cette conversion est juif à part entière
comme le Rabin je connais bon nombre bon
nombre de de de rabins qui n'étaient pas
juifs qui sont convertis au judaïsme qui
ont eu une conviction très forte et qui
ont fait des études très poussé et qui
sont devenus rabins donc c'est une
spécifité qui spécificité qui paraît
importante le fait qu'on ne cherche pas
à convertir mais qu'on permet à toute
personne qui le souhaite sincèrement
d'adhérer à la religion juive et de
devenir juif à part entière alors
comment se comment
se se fait cette
conversion il y a au concistoire de
Paris comme je le disais tout à l'heure
le tribunal rabinique qui s'appelle le
bêd qui a diverses missions notamment
liées à la famille mais notamment celle
de la conversion et les candidats à la
conversion sont reçus par des rabas
spécialisés qui s'entretiennent avec eux
je pense même qu'au jour d'aujourd'hui
il y a des psychologues qui participent
donc à ces réunions pour essayer de
faire prendre conscience aux personnes
voulant devenir juifes de la difficulté
d'être juif mais à la suite d'un d'un
parcours qui peut durer 1 an 2 ans 3 ans
selon les candidats lorsque le Rabin
chargé de la conversion estime que le
candidat est à même de franchir le pas
de Dir juif et bien
il il comparait devant un tribunal
rabinique composé de trois
rabins il devient juif il il il
manifeste son adhésion donc à la
religion juive et suite à cela
il passe par le bain rituel et il
devient juif à
partentière pardonnez-moi le financement
des
écoles le financement des écoles c'est
un problème extrêmement important car
vouloir diriger une école privée qu'elle
soit catholique protestante juive ou
autre c'est souvent quelque chose de
très très difficile alors ces écoles les
écoles privé de confession juives sont
financiers sont financés pardon par
l'écollage donc ce sont les parents qui
verse à l'école des frais de
scolarité pour les enfants dont les
parents sont déf défavorisés et ils sont
nombreux hélas il y a des bourses qui
sont
accordées à ces familles ces écoles
bénéficient également de dons elles
peuvent bénéficier de l'IG mais ce
financement est un financement
privé d'autres précision mesame pour le
pour le culte catholique le culte
catholique pardon les écoles sont toutes
quasiment sous contrat donc exactement
dans la même configuration précisée à
l'instant euh pour le contrôle des
conversions de notre côté nous ne sommes
pas non plus prosélite et nous nous
faisons extrêmement attention euh à la
démarche personnelle c'est-à-dire qu'une
personne qui demande le baptême rentre
dans une démarche longue de préparation
qu'on appelle le catcumena qui dure 2
ans au moins 2 ans pour bien s'assurer
que la personne fait une démarche
personnel et pas sous influence voilà
merci Monsieur R en ce qui concerne don
les écoles en 1882 au moment de la
licisation les protestants ont remis
leurs écoles à l'état ce qui explique
que il n'existe que 5 écoles sous
contrat et elles sont toutes en Alsace
puisque l'Alsace en 1982 n'était pas en
France donc ceci étant dit depuis
quelques années se crée des écoles
privées hors contrat évangélique et là
je me permettrai de préciser un point la
réglementation éducation nationale exige
5 ans de fonctionnement avant de passer
au contrat donc il y a nécessairement
une étape de souprivé hors contrat avant
d'arriver au contrat alors très
rapidement dans la présentation des
écoles
privées à confession il y a une chose
qui manque dans la présentation c'est la
reconnaissance de l'éducation nationale
ça a été dit mais aussi les villes pour
les enfants qui habitent la ville verse
une somme à la à l'école confessionnale
qu'elle soit juive ou catholique
euh musulmane c'est plus compliqué pour
qu'elle soit reconnue par l'Éducation
nationale mais moi moi je vois le le cas
de ma ville au
bervillierà où on on a trois écoles
trois quatre écoles confessionnal
catholique
juiv musulmane où il y a des subventions
de la Ville mais pour les enfants
uniquement qui habitent la ville il y a
également pour les collèges privés
confessionnal la la même chose au niveau
du conseil départemental pour les
enfants qui habitent bien sûr le
département
donc c'est important de le souligner
parce que c'est une deuxième
reconnaissance d'une part l'éducation
nationale et d'autre part les villes
pour les enfants qui
sont scolarisé dans dans ces écoles en
fait pour l'Église orthodoxe on n pas de
je dirais de de d'enseignement
confessionnel on n pas de d'école
privée du moins jusqu'à jusqu'à
aujourd'hui on n pas senti ce besoin là
d'aller vers cette logique là et donc il
y a une insertion je dirais dans l'école
républicaine dans les les dans les
écoles privées donc il y a pas une forme
de dualité par rapport à ça euh
deuxièmement sur les questions de
conversion c'est pratiquement le même
schéma je dirais qu'à décliner Anne
violen c'est que mais pas forcément en
fait cette durée là c'est une démarche
qui est essentiellement personnel et qui
reste dans une logique je dirais de
conversion de la personne à à un
processus puis à à à une fois à une
église jusqu'au moment de son de son
baptême euh et donc ça ça reste une
démarche personnelle il y a pas de je
dirais de contrôle dans le dans ce
sens-là il y a une démarche qui est en
relation avec un père spirituel un
prêtre et puis la personne qui rentre
dans un cycle de
catcumina ma réflexion plutôt générale
je dirais sur la question de des écoles
privées mais ça c'est quelque part je
c'est un Libanais qui parle en fait qui
a qui a vécu aussi d'une certain
libanais d'origine je suis très français
libanais d'origine mais quelque part je
je compare souvent la désintégration je
dirais de de l'État répu réublicain au
diban à travers cette logique de de
concurrence entre ce que j'appelle la
valeur nationale et la valeur
communautaire qui était toujours en
concurrence qui va prendre le dessus sur
l'autre est-ce que c'est la valeur
communautaire qui va prendre le dessus
sur la valeur national ou l'inverse le
c'est pour ça j'ai dit dans mon exposé
introductif que la vraie menace c'est
jusqu'où on peut pousser la
communautarisation sans remettre en
cause quelque part la valeur nationale
et donc toutes les logiques je dirais
d'écoles privées qui peuvent avoir une
logique historique je dirais ou une
logique communautaire c'est quelque
chose qui qui doit être manié en même
temps avec la nécessité je dirais
d'aller vers l'intégration et le
problème de financement c'est exactement
la même logique c'est-à-dire que le
problème c'est pas d'où vient le
financement mais comment on le traite
selon quelle logique de de transparence
dans quel objectif est-ce qu'on est dans
une logique et dans une tendance
d'intégration dans le tissus national où
on est en train de trouver des solutions
pour davantage de communautarisation qui
menace le tissu républicain Infiné C'est
ça la vraie à mon sens encore une fois
c'est une réflexion personnelle c'est
c'est C'est ça la vraie menace parce que
la communautarisation c'est la
désintégration de la communauté
nationale à la
longue monsieur Richard avec plaisir
merci madame la Présidente mesdamees
messieurs étant
alsacien je je peux témoigner de la
qualité de ce dialogue euh qui
fonctionne maintenant depuis de très
longues années puisque celui qui a
véritablement introduit les amorces de
ce dialogue c'était c'était feu feu le
sénateur rudelof Marcel rudelof qui
ensuite euh qui était sénateur qui a été
ensuite membre du Conseil
constitutionnel puis après après son
décès feu Adrien Zeller qui a beaucoup
fait aussi à cet égard en nommant pour
la première fois un un un pasteur dans
son cabinet pour pour s'occuper c'est
pas banal ça s'occuper du dialogue
interreligieux et puis maintenant
Philippe Richert qui continue en ayant
nommé lui aussi un pasteur pour suivre
ces
opérations je voudrais sans être trop
long vous dire rappeler juste une
anecdote que peut-être vous ne
connaissez pas avec ma collègue Nathalie
Goulet nous
étions co-président de la commission
d'enquête sur la lutte contre les
réseaux djihadistes
une commission d'enquête sénatoriale qui
a duré 6 mois et nous nous étions
déplacés à Strasbourg j j'y tenais un
peu puisque c'est de Strasbourg que sont
partis les premiers djihadistes moi je
me souviens étant strasbourgeois quand
j'ai appris ça je suis tombé de ma
chaise personne ne l'avait vu vu venir
savions naturellement qu'il y avait de
la radicalisation dans l'air mais pas
cela et donc cette commission d'enquête
s'est rendue à Strasbourg et entre
autres auditions euh nous avons eu celle
du proviseur euh je crois qu'il y a l'un
ou l'autre encore que le président de
l'Union bouddhiste est
parti personne présente ici qui
connaissent l'Alsace et qui connaîtront
peut-être un lycée qui s'appelle le
lycée
Matis qui se trouve dans dans une
zone on va pas appeler ça banlieu
s'agissant de Strasbourg parce que
Strasbourg n'est pas de banlieu mais
mais dans dans une zone allez un peu
difficile on va le dire comme ça c'est
pas la plus difficile mais elle est un
peu difficile et ce lycée est à la fois
lycée d'enseignement technologique lycée
professionnel et CFA centre de formation
d'apprentis pour celles et ceux qui qui
connaissent un peu la gradation des
établissements scolaires ils savent ce
qu'un CFA veut dire précisément dans une
zone pas facile quand même malgré les
les atténuations que je viens d'y
apporter un établissement qui doit faire
1200 1400 jeunes je me souviens plus
exactement et pour avoir interroger le
proviseur à l'époque ça remonte début de
l'année dernière sur notamment le
respect de la fameuse minute de silence
qui avait été demandé aux établissements
scolaires je pense que vous en souvenez
tous euh ce proviseur nous a dit que ben
non chez lui il y avait eu il y avait eu
aucun souci il eu aucun problème et donc
à l'étonnement quand même de celles et
ceux qui connaissaient les difficultés
qui étaient apparues dans un certain
nombre d'établissements nous lui avons
demandé pourquoi et il nous a répondu
que B ça posait pas de problème puisque
le dialogue interreligieux fonctionnait
dans cette établissement depuis de très
longues années il le disait d'autant
plus que c'est pas lui qui l'avait
introduit il s'avère que moi dans le
temps j'avais été membre du conseil
d'administration avec ma casquette de
conseil régional de ce lycée et donc je
savais que ça fonctionnait comme ça il y
avait un dialogue interreligieux qui
fonctionnait grâce à l'heure l'heure
entre guillemets confessionnelle ou
l'URE
religieuse l'heure de nous on appelit ça
l'heure de religion je votre serviteur a
suivi cette heure de religion il y a
déjà fortà j'ai jamais été dispensé
parce que savez que c'est jusqu'à une
période récente maintenant là il y a
l'observatoire de la laïcité qui nous
fait quelques petits soucis sur ça
mais jusqu'à une période
jusqu'actuellement d'ailleurs encore
c'est obligatoire de suivre le cours
sauf dispense sauf dispense moi j'ai
jamais été dispensé mes parents n'ont
jamais voulu me me dispenser donc j'ai
fait ça de la 11e à l'époque jusqu'en
terminale et donc
j'ai le sentiment que j'ai pas trop mal
voilà c'est ça mais pas trop mal Touré
mais peu importe je je reviens à
l'anecdote je connaissais ça et à
l'époque c'était une heure je
suis chrétien catholique
et c'était une heure de quasiment de
catéchisme mais il est vrai que
j'habitais pas Strasbourg j'habitais
vissembourg une petite commune qui à
l'époque avait 5000 habitants tout au
nord et là on y tenait voilà et petit à
petit on a vu évoluer cette heure de
religion en une heure dans certains
établissements qui voulaient bien le
faire de
d'heur d'information de sensibilisation
du fait et de compréhension du fait
religieux et donc le proviseur nous a
dit et ça je l'ignoris qu'il mettait
tous les élèves intéressés classe par
classe bien sûr hein pas
voilà face à à des
enseignants habilité hein pas pas pas
juste quelqu'un qui
qui qui c'était pas un prof d'histoire
habilité sur le fait religieux je suis
d'ailleurs pas comment il les formma
mais il en avait l'un ou l'autre et il
disait chaque semaine les gens n'ont pas
le choix je n'accepte pas les dispenses
je n'accepte pas les dispenses et ceci
c'est pas lui qui l'avait introduit ça a
était introduit depuis tous ses
prédécesseurs et il disait ça marche
très bien il y a des échanges tout le
temps forte forte prépondérance de de de
musulmans hein dans dans cet
établissement
euh ça marche tout le temps il y a pas
de problème et quand j'ai demandé ma
minute de silence il y a pas eu de souci
et je me souviens lui avoir posé la
question Nathalie tu étais là mais vous
l'avez fait comment cette minute de
silence cours par cours sale par s il
dit pas du tout moi j'ai réuni la
totalité de de de mes élèves tous tous
ceux qui étaient là 1200 1400 je sais
plus bien voilà dans le PAO dans le PAO
et puis je leur ai demandé de réserver
une minute de silence et vous savez que
quand on met plus il y a de monde plus
c'est difficile hein voilà et ben il me
dit on aurait entendu une mouche volée
ils ont respecté tous personne a levé la
main personne n' regardé ailleurs
personne ne s'est tourné et cetera et
CEA donc moi ça m'a vraiment beaucoup
ébranlé et ça m'amène à la question
euh Nathalie m'a dit que vous vous vous
étiez naturellement favorable au
dialogue je dis enfin naturellement vous
étiez favorable au dialogue
interreligieux vous le pratiquez au plan
national enfin là où vous êtes
euh est-ce que est-ce que vous pensez
que ce dialogue interreligieux peut
ailleurs qu'en Alsace hein voilà
ailleurs qu'en Alsace aboutir à des
résultats de ce
type je je vais rester très très humble
parce
que le dialogue religieux fonctionne
maintenant je dit tout à l'heure depuis
au moins 20 ans et monte en gamme
vraiment d'année en année monte en
gamme on on a eu le résultat sur la
minut de silence dont je viens de parler
mais ça nous a pas empêché d'avoir les
premiers candidats au jihad ça nous a
pas empêché ce qui reste montre que si
c'est une des façons éventuellement de
limiter les conduites déviantes c'est
pas quand même la solution c'est pas la
seule solution et si c'est une des
solutions il faut naturellement
développer massivement ce type de de de
dialogue alors le conseil régional fait
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup sur
ça le mois de l'autre enfin beaucoup de
choses qui qui qui concourt à à cette à
ce à ce dialogue euh voilà ma question
c'est est-ce que vous croyez que c'est
duplicable malgré les lacunes euh au
plan national est-ce que vous pensez que
cette cette heure euh je vais très loin
là cette heure de d'information civique
ou morale cher à Madame Valot Belkassem
pourrait être pourrait être utilisé pour
ça effectivement nous en avons déjà
parlé mais pour pouvoir répondre à
Monsieur Richard peut-être en quelques
mots si vous permettez je vais je vais
dire quelques mot nous disions les uns
et les autres que le dialogue
interreligieux était extrêmement
fructueux et je je donnais l'exemple des
des représentants du CFCM le président
notamment qui est venu à plusieurs
reprises au Consistoire central et le
président du Consistoire de Paris qui
s'est rendu à la mosqu de de de Paris et
dans d'autres lieux de culte musulmans
de façon régulière mais une initiative
qui est extrêmement intéressante émane
d'un d'un Rabin qui est également
professeur il est professeur à la
Faculté de Strasbourg mais il est Rabin
de Ris Orangis c'est le Rabin Michel
Sarfati et ce Rabin a créé les amitiés
judéo-musulmanes et il a signé la France
il le fait régulièrement avec un bus
et ce bus permet de faire rencontrer de
jeunes musulmans et de jeunes juif pour
faire
tomber les les barrières qui pourraient
exister la vraie difficulté c'est
que le le recteur d'Alil Boubaker
d'autres imams comme l'imam chalgoui
l'imam de de Bordeaux et d'autres sont
des gens extrêmement ouverts mais je
Nimagine pas que les milieux salafistes
ai véritablement envie de dialoguer
notamment avec les représentants de la
communauté juive ou peut-être même avec
les représentants des autres communautés
mais cette minute de silence moi moi
également j'ai connu cette heure qu'on
appelait cours de religion dans les
lycées alsaciens c'est extrêmement
enrichissant on ne connaît pas dans le
reste de la France c'est vrai que cette
minute de silence paraît extrêmement
importante et c'est cette de
réflexion qui est proposé par la
ministre de de l'éducation nationale
pourrait effectivement permettre de
faire faire connaître le fait religieux
des uns et des autres aux élèves et
permettre un un rapprochement et de
faire tomber les préventions des uns et
des
autres il me semble que effectivement
nous avons déjà dit tous notre
attachement au dialogue interreligieux
et le const ça que ça existe sur le
terrain je veux dire mais ça les
difficultés ne viennent pas de la loi de
1905 qui ne dit rien à la matière et
donc qui n'empêche rien mais qui
viennent plutôt de l'organisation de
chacun des ministères concernés par
exemple pour reprendre l'exemple précis
en Alsace et en Moselle il y a
effectivement tout un budget pour
rémunérer les intervenants en la matière
ce sont des gens rémunérés et formés et
les églises ont beaucoup fait un effort
depuis quelques années pour développer
ce que ce dont vous avez parlé et elles
y ont investi beaucoup de formation
et si on a tant de difficulté en France
de l'intérieur pour mettre en place cet
enseignement Laï du fait religieux c'est
justement le problème de la formation
qui va l'assurer don je vois cette
difficulté du côté deéducation nationale
avoir les moyens deux et même difficulté
du côté de pénitentiaire les homoniers
sont toujours très favorables au travail
interreligieux la difficulté c'est un
certain nombre de dispositions
réglementaires qui prévoit qu'en théorie
c'est chaque culte qui donc je crois que
les nous ne pouvons donc être favorable
à cette idée mais ça veut dire qu'il
faut que tous les ministères concernés
fassent évoluer les textes en la
matière euh pour notre part je voudrais
revenir un peu peut-être sur une
précision terminologique euh la notion
dialogue interreligieux tel que nous on
la conçoit entre les différentes
confessions elle a aussi une dimension
théologique
euh qui n'est pas du tout euh qui n'est
pas qui n'intervient pas j'imagine dans
le cadre d'un enseignement euh scolaire
qui est l'enseignement du fait religieux
je je préfère préciser ça parce qu'il
pourrait y avoir euh des confusions hein
par contre je pense qu'effectivement il
est très important qu'il y ait cette
connaissance réciproque euh des des du
culte de chacun et je pense que ça se
fait en tout cas moi j'ai connaissance
d'une école catholique où cela se fait
c'est-à-dire qu'on fait intervenir un
imam on fait intervenir un rabin on fait
intervenir un pasteur de manière à ce
que les élèves euh puisse connaître les
différentes religions et comment elles
fonctionnent et que et savoir qui on est
et si on est si on sait qui on est on
peut discuter voilà madame
Goulet je voulais avant de que madame la
Présidente clôture cette session d'abord
vous remercier d'être d'être venu euh
vous indiquez que c'est une c'est une
mission d'information qui est assez
délicate cont tenu du du sujet et que
chacun doit apporter sa pierre à à
l'édifice d'une meilleure compréhension
de l'autre et de l'altérité et je
voudrais dire à monsieur bchinger qui au
début de son intervention au cours de
son intervention et à chacune de ces
interventions a fait part de son de des
menaces de l'antisémitisme et et et du
du ressenti d'insécurité
euh que comme nous l'avons dit
euh au aux personnalités de la
communauté musulmane qui sont venus à de
très nombreuses reprises déjà devant
nous mon cher collègue qu'à la fois les
musulmans et les Juifs ont toute leur
place dans la République et dans la
sécurité et que j'espère que ce
sentiment pourra très rapidement se
dissiper parce que ça ça ne correspond
pas à à à la France plurielle et tel que
telle que nous la la concevons et je
voulais quand même au titre de de du
rapporteur vous vous faire cette
observation je voulais aussi avant de de
vous saluer rebondir et et confirmer je
dirais les propos de de ma collègue
rapporteur cette mission d'information
euh pte sur des sujets qui nous
concernent tous dans notre vie
quotidienne et nous souhaitons et nous
avons cette volonté de de la réaliser
dans le cadre de la République dans le
cadre d'un État laïque qui permet à
chacun et chacun une euh d'exercer s'il
le souhaite euh sa religion et pouvoir
euh non seulement euh comment on va dire
se baser sur ces valeurs extrêmement
fortes mais pouvoir aussi être pour nous
l'occasion de réaffirmer que ces valeurs
sont essentielles à notre République et
que notre pays se doit et il le fait de
permettre encore une fois chacun et
chacune euh quand ils ont fait ce choix
et bien de pratiquer leur religion merci
merci encore à
tous le problème n'est pas le dialogue
interreligieux mais le malaise qui peut
existerer lorsque certains identifient
la religion à un combat politique ou
social cette phrase pourrait résumer à
elle seule l'audition que vous venez de
voir les différents représentants des
cultes des confessions de France sont
intervenus devant les sénateurs de la
mission d'information sur l'islam une
audition que vous pouvez tevir et revoir
en VOD sur notre site
publicsenat.fr très bonne suite des
programmes sur les chaînes
parlementaires